I'm outside El Dorado High School near
Washington and Nellis where CCSD spent
26 million dollars on security upgrades
at this school which includes new
security cameras that you can see right
there after a teacher was attacked I
spoke with an expert who said CCSD needs
to focus on pre-incident prevention
rather than just security
people are really focused on
response
we've it's like programmed in our heads
right it's like in our DNA the cost
prevention is so minuscule compared to
what they're spending on security
Rickshaw has been in the school violence
prevention field for 22 years he works
with large school districts around the
country such as Tulsa and Oklahoma City
while based here he is not associated
with our district but he believes
schools are spending too much money on
security we have to start looking at
that pre-instate prevention because we
can't respond our way out of this
there's just no way
I mean in 2022
there were over 300 school shootings
that's the most there's ever been last
week at the Clark County School District
Board of Trustees Vicki cridel of the
National Education Association of
Southern Nevada shared her concerns with
the rise in violence against teachers in
December three juveniles were arrested
for allegedly attacking two teachers at
Legacy High School as we saw with the
Legacy incident our new Panic buttons
won't save us
but we were hoping that additional
actions with safety would follow
we haven't seen any other measures to
improve safety put into place
CCSD introduced that instant alert
system last year for staff to use an
emergency situations it has been
activated 560 times so far this school
year about 250 times it was for student
code of conduct violations reporting
live at El Dorado High School Joshua
peguero eight news now thank you Joshua
to address safety concerns CCSD banned
students this school year from using
cell phones during school hours and
spent about six million dollars on
installing additional security cameras
on school buses